I used to be the smart I made sure how
the smartest guy in the room yeah now if
I'm the smartest guy in the room I'm in
the wrong you're in the wrong room
I believe this philosophy of do it now
99.9% of the people are ziering
themselves out there doing 28 days a
month not 31 need motivation watch a top
10 with believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from starting with nothing to becoming a
millionaire by age 30 to going broke
losing it all and then gaining it all
back again and more he's David Meltzer
and here's my take on his top ten rules
of success
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one shift your energy you can think and
say and do certain things and believe
certain things but if you carry an
energy that's different it doesn't
matter what you're trying to manifest
and let me give you an example there's a
lot of people that date the same person
again and again and again or they have
the same business problem again and
again again yeah the same obstacles yeah
no matter what they do you seemed it
what why why is this always happen to us
it's because you carry an energy I drink
what I analyzed and you know I went to
India and kind of learned this stuff
about myself is number one my siblings
were all hyper intelligent students they
all went to the Ivy League's so I kind
of chip on my shoulder that I didn't go
to Harvard Penn or Columbia okay my
siblings were much more academic great
so I had that going then when I was
little as hyper and they were good
students by Grandma who my mom was a
teacher would take us after school was
this wise old kind of Yoda type of
character yeah and she would always say
to me I go grandma I'm bored
right I don't want to study yes he goes
only stupid people get bored smart
people think things to do well this
changed my cellular memory
that's right neural pathways and in
demised code that's our DNA so my energy
shifted what did that mean though that
means I projected my insecurity about
being stupid yes maybe an eagle driven
guy yes who then surrounded himself with
the wrong people yeah I used to be the
smart I made sure how the smartest guy
in the room yeah now if I'm the smartest
guy in the room
you're in the wrong room rule number two
do it now
the second thing is I believe in this
philosophy of do it now which is kind of
realms on this whole kind of get the K
can you introduce me right now
immediately what anything's coming with
my life I asked myself can I do it now
so hey can you refer this yeah hold on
okay I'll make phone calls you've been
amazing it's like almost a DD but it's
not it's just if you don't the minute
talk about saving time anything you can
do now you at least save twice as much
time the minute you don't do something
now it'll take you minimum twice as much
time to do it plus you got to remember
it plus you could become statistically
unsuccessful exponentially unsuccessful
the longer you wait on it so I actually
have now am I do it now strategy not
only do things now but I have a folder
which is called do it now so it's things
that I would do now if I was capable of
something that's that important so I
immediately after I'm doing it now and
doing this how good am I do it now
folder so I won't forget and knock it
out all in those are the important
things so I have this system of doing it
now which only saves me time and makes
me more sophistical a successful rule
number three survive failure you're sort
of me really is one of being able to
rebuild and so few people a can do it
and be the ones that can and have don't
want to talk about it and so how do you
think about failure how have you
conceptualized in your mind why are you
so able to talk so openly about it you
know I did interview with Ryan Leaf but
we were talking about big failures and
his failure was even more public in mine
but the number one shameful thing of
losing everything and the most
courageous thing was to face our mothers
you know you talk about the public and
here I had I said today I'd sheriffs
lined up at my Rancho Santa Fe home and
moving trucks to take everything out I
hope you know 33 homes alone in San
Diego gone a golf course is Ski Mountain
so beyond my community and associates
and all of this and I was already
working for Lee this is from past
transgressions I was already on my path
and journey of fulfillment but the
hardest thing was to walk through my
mom's house in cha oh I get choked up I
had to tell her that not only did I fail
her myself
but I fell over the altar it's really
really tough
so that failure to me was the toughest
part you know and so for me all the
other things were just learning
experiences but I had to get over the
shame of that you know here they took my
mom's house my dream of getting rich was
only to buy my mom a house in a car
that's yeah I grew up with nothing
six kids single mom so for me to make it
back I was already on that journey and I
felt as if I could stay in a place of
giving and faith and and I mean faith in
myself and faith in the universe faith
and others of service that everything
would come back to me and it did rule
number four don't take anyone's advice
you went to Tulane law school yes sir
and you graduate there and within nine
months tell them what happens because I
want you all to hear the ups and downs
of real life business and real life from
one of the most successful people in the
country so what happens at a lawsuit so
out of law school I have two choices for
jobs and it's a recession right one was
to be a real lawyer oil and gas
litigator
you know big money I all I wanted to do
is be rich is why I went to law school
and then ii wanted to work in the
internet and i got offered a job to sell
legal research online buy less
publishing okay big big legal publisher
and so i go to my mom cuz you'll
appreciate this i go to my mom okay what
should i do mom a big advisor you know i
grew up with a single mom six kids and
she without blinking it's like you need
to be a real lawyer because this
internet thing is a bad so she calls it
a fad right I always say cuz I like to
teach lessons the biggest lesson of my
life was just because somebody loves you
doesn't mean they give you good
vicen and I see so many people
entrepreneurs in relationships they ask
for advice for people that don't know
anything my was a second grade teacher
right what I've seen beautiful soul but
not a technology expert now and I would
have all those I think slowed down or
you know you know not allowed me to have
the acceleration add so I took the
technology job right you know single
money-hungry in a sales job in the
Internet
so be very careful just because you love
them or they love you of thinking they
have some expertise in an area that you
don't right they probably don't and so
oftentimes we take advice from the wrong
person to rails our dream so that's less
than one more thing to yeah we end up
resenting them which is worse so all the
people that love us most you end up
resenting them because they gave us bad
advice and meanwhile we should be
accountable because we asked a secondary
teacher for internet advice mmm it's
good that's the worst part rule number
five practice gratitude I tell people
today if you want to change your life
it's as easy as two simple words thank
you in fact the best habit that you can
have I've done research for the last ten
years in quantum physics metaphysics
physics and I will tell you the best
effective habit that you can have is to
say thank you before you go to bed and
before and when you wake up if you can
say or think thank you before you go to
bed and say it and think it when you
wake up for 30 straight days I guarantee
you it'll change your life
now how many here think you can do that
for 30 straight days and variably
everybody raises their hand the saddest
part is by tonight half of you will not
say or think thank you by the morning
another half of you will not say or
think thank you and unfortunately in
three days almost all of us will forget
to say thank you I've given you the
easiest way gratitude to change your
life and yet we're so far in our own way
we can't even say thank you for 30
straight days rule number six ask big
you might as well do as many good deeds
as you can open as many doors smile as
many people hug as many people as you
can and then when you create your void
of giving a service that's big that's in
this human vibration
this pragmatic world asks big ask for at
all does it will come to you and that's
I think something I did subconsciously
when I was 25 right out of law school
and it's something I do consciously
subconsciously and unconsciously now I
asked to empower 75,000 people I want to
change the world to make people happy
and who are you asking that of the
universe so whatever you believe in and
whatever you believe in I don't care if
it's God Jesus Muhammad Joseph Smith the
12th man if you're a Seahawks fan I
don't care but ask ask the universe ask
who you think put it out there you know
there's three ways you got what you
think say and do that's one way to put
it out there
subconsciously there are no pathways in
your mind 40,000 of the same thoughts
put it out there and then finally your
energy your DNA your fingerprint on life
that's what truly puts it out there and
that system of consciousness
subconscious - unconscious is what
allows you to truly attract rapidly and
accurately what you want rule number
seven provide value we're goal oriented
people yes right we played sports you
know it's all about winning yeah and so
what I used to do is I'd attach once I
graduate high school I'll be happy I get
a scholarship to college I graduate all
this and every time it occurred I still
was in the same state of mind yes what I
learned to do was detach the happiness
this bliss yeah from the outcome now the
difference is most people get concerned
like well how can you be motivated
without an outcome no no no I have
outcomes and I pray every morning this
is a truly abundant thing my first
prayer every morning is may God put it
in front of me 10 people that I can help
that you could help I think you can help
and I can help and I've shifted the
paradigm of value understanding outcomes
and happiness you need so I used to and
maybe you'll understand this I'm a great
salesman you are I can over sell back
and sell and lie to you I can cheat to
you I haven't done it when I was in my
20s I would shade the truth you know I
sold stuff sure and it didn't make me
feel good what happened was I created a
void for me to fill all the time I make
you promises and I live on this premise
I'm going to exceed everybody's
expectations that's my goal right yeah
let's start first of all talk about
[ __ ] yes right how many
have you actually write exceeding a
business the right exceeded the other
part of his explanation very rarely very
rarely especially if you've set those
expectations artificially high which I
did write the way you exceeded is by not
setting them charging or selling it
right that's why I started writing right
but what was cool was I started with
this prayer and then I said what if I
started the day with this energy that
God put a whole bag of hundred-dollar
bills in front of me and my job all day
long she was to trade $100 bills for 20
so whatever I did was I was gonna
provide value as a father as a husband
do as a business partner as a partners
of philanthropists and just you'll see I
asked everyone either unconditionally
how can I be of service
you do you said to me the first time we
spoke how kind how can you service I
mean it yeah I know you do and I and I
know that that's my biggest blessing I'm
not lazy I wake up before I am I work
really hard for others yeah and but I
also when I work hard for others I have
my intention my focus on what I want
rule number eight focus on being the
best let's say that uh you want to be
the best fitness trainer in the world I
don't know but let's just say you want
to be the trainer okay would you like to
be the best trainer in the world and
make a lot of money or just be the best
trainer yeah so what it doesn't I want
the money comes so it's not about like
what's not about the money
that's not my end alright I don't attach
the money as my goal I attached it my
consistent persistent pursuit of my
potential being the best trainer I
guarantee the best trainer in America
makes it among the best book you know
Bill Parcells one of my favorite coaches
he got into coaching not to make money
John Madden you know he is John Madden
got into coaching not to make money but
putting his name on EA Sports on Madden
he makes more money than anyone else for
his name
but it's not about the money why does he
do it because he helps so many people
without money
right the universe rewards you money is
just an energy rule number nine be
consistent there's a consistency that
makes people successful and what happens
is we lie to ourselves and I'll use
health because you're an expert at it
but I see this in nutrition in an
exercise people will tell me after one
month gosh why did I get incremental
results or no results at all I said
because you zeroed yourself out the kids
that showed up during spring break to
the event that I had that the ones that
were there and they had a lot of other
distractions they're the ones that don't
zero out they're the ones that get the
exponential power of the universe
meaning if I do something every day day
one I get X to the first stay twos to
second third for third fourth fifth most
people when it comes to nutrition
they're always these six they zero
themselves out then they start over for
a second and during a month it means
zero themself out three or four times at
the end of the month they didn't get the
exponential results if you stick to
something every day this idea of being
more interested really asking the extra
questions going the extra mile which is
completely empty in my opinion if you
want no competition in your life
go the extra mile 99.9% of the people
are ziering themselves out they're doing
28 days a month not 31 and rule number
10 the last one before a very special
bonus clip is be radically humble what
is something you wish you knew when you
were 21 oh that's an easy question for
me
two words radical humility I wish
somebody would have taught me the
ability that I did know and it's the
biggest problem I have with my interns
and young associates of my business you
don't know what you don't know so feel
good about asking for help asking for
help is giving a gift to people like me
you know when you ask for help you
become an investment of that person and
then don't forget like you said earlier
just because you don't have a lot of
money or experience doesn't mean you
can't help that person so whenever if
someone would have told me David be
radically humble ask for help and then
provide help to others
and that's my signature teaching tool
here is hey ask for help and then always
follow up with what can I do for you now
I've got a bonus clip from Dave around
how to be authentic that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions time to move from watching
another video to taking action in your
life for your business so here we go
question number one how can you shift
your energy to positive in your morning
routine number two what is on your list
that you need to do right now and number
three what are you grateful for
who are some investors that you have
learned from and have helped you a great
question so you know Steve Wynn was one
for me that had been a great great
mentor just understanding the
relationship and the energy to money and
the transparency of how to get to the
point I used to be an over seller a
back-end seller even you could say well
I hate to say this but a bush just you
know and and I thought that I was
fooling everybody and Steve Wynn taught
me I'd rather people hate you for who
you are they love you for who you're not
because if it's not there yet they're
gonna let you know and then back end the
truth always comes out so especially as
did entrepreneur just tell the truth as
painful as it may be because they may
have a solution and they're going to
most of all trust you and help you
beyond in the back end having it back
end sell someone because you over sold
them raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that that people
passion and not one drop of those
self-worth depends on your acceptance of
a
if you want more Dave check out the live
one-on-one hangout interview that I did
with him there's tons of value there the
link is right next to me I think you're
gonna enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there there's two things
that that two schools of thought and two
ways to go one is simply stimulate
interest